so my name is sandy and i'm here to talk
to you about orchestrating
software-defined assets with dagster
some quick background on myself
if you've heard me speak at a data
conference before it was probably a long
time ago in my cloudera days when i was
contributing to hadoop and spark and
co-wrote this book about data science
i spent the middle chunk of my career as
a practicing data scientist building
pipelines and machine learning models at
a couple different companies
which was a fun time but also a
frustrating time
because i found that there were big gaps
in the tooling that i needed to do my
job
so a couple years ago i came back to the
world of data tooling to try to fill
what i saw as the biggest gap i joined
the elemental team to work on dagstar
but before we get to that gap and before
we get to dagstar i'd like to step away
from the world of data entirely and talk
about front-end engineering
and cluster orchestration
and devops
these domains have something in common
which is that they've all gone through a
big transition in the last decade or two
so we used to build websites using
jquery but now we use react
we used to orchestrate our compute
clusters using yarn or mesos but now we
use kubernetes
and we used to provision infrastructure
using high powered shell scripts but now
we use terraform
so technology transitions happen all the
time
but what's interesting here is that all
these transitions have something in
common which is that they move from an
imperative paradigm to a declarative
paradigm
for those of you who aren't familiar
with these terms here are some crude
definitions so under an imperative
paradigm
you give commands telling your system
what to do change this change that
with the declarative paradigm you
describe the end state that you want
your system to be in and then you let a
control plane manage change
so what's going on here why do we see
this pattern of change
if you take a closer look at the history
of any of these software domains you
start to get a sense of it
so the initial challenge is about speed
to build stuff
it takes developers a long time to get
basic things done like provision an ec2
server or change what shows up in a text
box
tools come along that speed this up
dramatically so for example jquery makes
it stupidly easy to change what shows up
in the text box
by making it so easy to build stuff
these tools solve the initial problem
but they create another one which is
that now people build a lot of stuff
it becomes difficult to reason about all
this stuff what text boxes are expected
to appear on the page and what text are
those boxes expected to contain
so finally new tools arrive to tackle
this problem and these new tools are
built declaratively instead of
imperatively
that's because declarative tools are
highly effective at taming complexity
they do this in a couple main ways
so first they ask users to explicitly
state their intentions and expectations
which means you get an unambiguous plan
that's inspectable by anyone
second they provide a principled way of
managing change
instead of an unstructured logs of
things that you did you can ask the
system why did you make this change why
would you put this value inside this
text box and the system can give you a
clear answer
so now let's talk about a domain with
complexity and change of the wazoo
and that domain is data
in the world of data where are we on
this tooling journey
well it used to be very hard to build
stuff
10 years ago if you wanted to calculate
some statistic over every event on your
website you need to set up a compute
cluster with 20 different services and
even the simplest operations could take
tens of minutes to complete
since then we've built powerful
databases and data processing engines
that make this all effortless so now
with snowflake or spark you can write
three lines of code and get a result in
a couple of seconds
and we've built workflow managers that
allow you to easily chain a bunch of
data processing steps together
building data pipelines has never been
easier
the result is that we build tons of data
pipelines so even at medium-sized
organizations it's not uncommon to have
hundreds of tables machine learning
models and data sets
and tens of thousands of lines of code
that are responsible for generating them
this code typically spans different
compute frameworks and storage systems
so some will happen in a data warehouse
some in spark some in snowflake pandas
tensorflow etc
here's a little example from my past
life working with health insurance data
to answer a simple question like how
many people were admitted to the
hospital during this time period we
ended up with a chain of intermediate
data sets which spanned three compute
frameworks
so there's a lot that's great about this
picture maintaining intermediate data
sets lets us reuse valuable data
cleaning work
and supporting multiple ways of
processing data gives us the flexibility
to use the right tool for the job
but without extremely careful
shepherding this complexity naturally
devolves into chaos
we end up with multiple versions of the
same things created by different people
or even by the same people at different
times
it's hard to distinguish trustworthy
maintained data from one-off artifacts
that went stale months ago
discovering how a table or machine
learning model is generated often
requires a heroic act of code spelunking
and debugging requires untangling a
complicated history of state mutations
this chaos interferes with our ability
to accomplish our goals
we can't trust our data because we don't
know how it's generated or how it's
expected to be kept up to date
and we spend most of our energy waiting
through our existing system so we don't
have the mental space to expand it
which is all to say that i think we're
solidly in this upper right box managing
all the data in pipelines is still
really hard
what would it take to bring a
declarative approach to data management
and tame this chaos
so a declarative approach fundamentally
revolves around the declarative entity
in front-end engineering the entity is a
ui component
you declare the ui components that you
want to exist and how you want them to
be rendered
in devops it's a resource you declare
the servers or other infrastructure
components that you want to exist
and what you want their properties to be
so what's the declarative entity for
data
it's the asset
an asset is a database table a machine
learning model a report any object
produced by your data platform that
captures some understanding of the world
it could be a source asset that's
ingested directly from some external
system it could be a derived asset it's
built from source assets or other
derived assets
creating and maintaining data assets is
the main reason that people build data
pipelines in the first place
assets function as the interfaces
between different teams they're the
objects that we inspect when we want to
debug problems
and they're ultimately the products that
data teams build for the rest of the
world
managing assets declaratively means
defining them in software
it means writing code to specify the set
of assets that you expect to exist and
how you expect those assets to relate to
each other
an orchestrator
then becomes responsible for keeping the
contents of physical storage aligned
with those definitions
materialization is the word we use for a
physical manifestation of an asset for
example example an actual table in a
database or file in a file
system if this all sounds a little bit
abstract that's fine i'm going to spend
the rest of this talk making this
concrete and walking through the
implications
and i'm going to do that through the
lens of dagstar so for those of you who
aren't familiar dagster is an open
source orchestration platform
we recently introduced software-defined
assets as a core element of dagster's
data model
with this new abstraction dexter becomes
a critical tool not just for running
workflows but also for organizing
managing and evolving data
a software-defined asset specifies an
asset that you intend to exist
as well as how to compute that asset's
contents
assets don't come out of nowhere they're
produced by computations which in
dagstar we call ups
to get a table in your data warehouse
you normally have to run some code that
puts it there
and those computations normally operate
on other assets
so a software defined asset is basically
the combination of these three things it
has an asset key which identifies the
asset that it corresponds to for example
the name of a table in a database or the
path to a file and a file system
it has an op which is the function that
can be run to produce the asset
it has upstream asset keys which
reference assets that we supply as
inputs to the op that we use to compute
our asset
and these upstream asset keys usually
correspond to asset keys of other
software defined assets which means that
a group of software-defined assets
naturally forms a graph
here's a software-defined asset that's
built using dagsor's python api
the name of the decorated function
defines the asset key so in this case
the asset represents a forecast of
activity on some website
the implementation of the decorated
function is the op
so in this case it uses pandas but ops
can use any compute framework and then
asset doesn't even need to be tabular
data for example it could be a machine
learning model or a set of images
the arguments to this function designate
the upstream assets that this asset is
based on in this case it's an asset
called activity daily stats which holds
historical data on our website's
activity
something you might notice here is that
i'm not showing any code that actually
reads or writes to or from physical
storage
the op is a pure function
to support this functional style of
programming dagstar allows the code that
writes an asset to storage to be
provided separately and shared by
multiple assets
it's not a requirement to do it that way
but it's preferred because it makes
assets more testable
but decorating a python function isn't
the only way to build a software-defined
asset so if you wanted to find an asset
using sql a dbt model actually fits all
the criteria that we talked about for a
software-defined asset
let's walk through one
this activity daily stats asset has the
same core components as the python asset
the name of the file which determines
the name of the dbt model is the asset
key
the select statement is the op it's what
we run to compute the contents of the
asset
and the refs are upstream asset keys
they point to assets that this
computation depends on
dexter can actually model dependencies
between assets defined in python and
assets to find in dbt
it does this by offering a python
utility that makes it easy to load all
the models in a dbt project as
software-defined assets
once you define a set of assets in code
either directly in python or by loading
them from an external tool you can start
working with them in dagster's web ui so
here's how you tell dexter to scan a
python package and make all the assets
inside of it
loadable from the web ui
and here's that web ui we have a visual
representation of all the assets that we
were just looking at in code
this is all open source by the way you
can get to this view by pip installing a
package and running a single command
so at the bottom we've got our activity
forecast asset which is the one that we
defined in python
right above that we've got the activity
daily stats asset which is the one that
we defined using dbt
and above that we've got a couple other
assets which came from models in our dbt
project
if you've worked with tools that show
dags this might look a little familiar
but there are a couple of key difference
off the bat that i'd like to point out
so the first is that each node
represents an asset not a task or up
in fact multiple assets can be generated
by the same op
these three dbt assets are generated by
the same run dbt op which invokes the
dbt command line tool
the second is that there's no central
dag artifact that holds the dependency
structure
each asset on its own knows about the
upstream assets that it depends on
this makes it scalable to large numbers
of assets you don't need a central team
to maintain a code artifact that
captures all of them
so here we're looking at just the assets
that i showed you the definitions of
we've also got links to assets that
these assets depend on but that are
loaded by dexter separately
so at this point all we're looking at
here is a set of asset definitions
they correspond to code in our git repo
not artifacts in physical storage that
is they have no associated
materializations
but dexter doesn't just track asset
definitions it also allows you to
materialize assets and tracks those
materializations
so we can click this button on the upper
right to materialize all the assets that
are shown here
that launches a run which contains a log
of everything that happens as we execute
the computations that materialize these
assets
when the run is complete each asset now
has a materialization
that is it now exists in persistent
storage and dexter knows about that and
when it arrived there
dexter knows some other useful stuff as
well and if we dive into one of these
assets we can see it
here's the page for an individual asset
our activity forecast asset that we
defined in python it contains details
about the asset and its history of
materializations
a materialization isn't just a record
saying that a computation ran it's a
description of the object that was
produced by the computation
dexter lets users plug in code that
records runtime metadata about the asset
that's being materialized
so for example we've recorded a few
things about this materialization we've
recorded the number of rows the file
system pathway it's stored a sample of
the data and the set of columns and
their data types
this asset focus view is especially
valuable when you shift to the
perspective of someone who depends on an
asset
so let's imagine that we're in our bi
tool we're using this asset to try to
understand what the future holds for our
website
we notice something fishy
maybe some of the data that we expect to
be there is missing
so we can pull up this search box in
dagstr
type in the asset that we care about and
get to the asset page that we were
looking at before
from that page we have all this
information about the asset its
materializations its dependencies its
metadata at our fingertips and if we
have permissions we can directly launch
a run to re-materialize the asset and
patch up the issue
so to summarize what we just saw there
software-defined assets provide a layer
above our physical storage that allows
us to express what assets we expect to
exist and how those assets are produced
the software-defined asset graph is
based on assets defined in code which
means that practices for managing and
evolving code can be harnessed for
managing data
we can launch runs to materialize our
assets which means computing their
contents and writing those contents to
physical storage
by focusing our tooling on assets
instead of tasks it becomes easy to get
visibility into what has happened with
the assets that we care about
so we define some assets and materialize
them which is cool but it's not enough
and it's not enough because assets are
constantly changing
new upstream data is constantly arriving
and we're constantly changing the code
that derives our assets from that
upstream data
the result is that our asset
materializations naturally drift from
their definitions over time
when that drift occurs we need to launch
computations to bring those
materializations in line with our
definitions
and launching computations at the right
job at the right time is typically the
job of an orchestrator
traditionally orchestrators are systems
that are responsible for a few things
they invoke computations at the right
time
they model the dependencies between
computations
and they track what computations ran
this makes orchestrators the natural
experts on a few topics
they know when stuff happens they know
when stuff is going to happen and they
know what it takes to make something
happen
and because they're experts on these
things they hold the key to answering
some of the most important questions
that we end up having about our assets
so for example is this asset up to date
what do i need to run to refresh this
asset
what code and data were used to generate
this asset
after pushing a change
what assets need to be updated
when will this asset be updated next
but if you try to pose these questions
to a traditional orchestrator you'll
immediately run into the issue they have
no idea what an asset is
they can tell you what tasks have
completed
what tasks are meant to run after each
other but not about how any of that has
to do with the assets that these tasks
are reading and writing
they're ill-equipped to answer these
questions because asset is not central
to their data model
if we could conceive of orchestration in
a way that's centered on assets we'd
have an extremely powerful set of tools
for managing and understanding them
so we talked about the job of a
traditional orchestrator the job of an
asset orchestrator is a little different
it's to manage change in data assets
dexter supports two approaches to
orchestration for assets
the first one looks very similar to how
scheduling works in traditional
orchestrators except that it focuses on
assets instead of tasks you can select a
set of assets re-materialized at some
regular cadence or via a sensor based on
arbitrary logic
the second one fully leans into the
declarative approach you tell your
orchestrator to launch computations that
resolve discrepancies between your asset
definitions and their materializations
in storage
so let's start with a
one on the left as a way to get our feet
wet
this code tells dagster to run a job
every day at midnight and that job
materializes a subset of the assets in
our asset graph so it targets assets not
tasks
here's what this scheduled job looks
like in dagstr's ui so up on the top
here we can see when it's going to run
and the job includes just the assets
that we've selected we can still see the
data lineage between the assets inside
the job and the assets outside the job
putting the schedule on the asset
instead of on a task makes it easy for
stakeholders to answer questions about
when assets will be updated next
when they navigate to the page for an
asset they can see the frequency that
it's going to be updated at
so just by framing scheduling in terms
of assets instead of tasks the
orchestrator becomes an ideal system for
answering these questions that we looked
at earlier
it eliminates the friction of
translating between assets and tasks and
it can speak authoritatively about how
assets will be updated as time passes
so that gets us pretty far
but fully realizing the benefits of a
declarative approach requires going
farther
to an orchestration approach that's
based on reconciliation
here's how it
works first we observe discrepancies
between how the world is and how the
world should be
then we launch computations that are
required to make those two match
the most basic discrepancy in need of
reconciliation is when you have a
software-defined asset with no
materializations
to make the set of assets in physical
storage match the set of assets you've
declared you need to materialize the
asset
a related discrepancy is when you're
working with a partitioned asset and
only some of its partitions have
materializations
another discrepancy is when the contents
of an asset don't reflect the contents
of the upstream assets that it depends
on
so if the most recent materialization of
the asset occurred earlier than the most
recent materialization of the upstream
asset
then it's likely that the asset's
contents are stale
dagster raises its discrepancy with an
upstream changed indicator
a fourth discrepancy is when the
metadata on an asset definition doesn't
match the metadata from its latest
materialization
so here's an asset whose definition
includes metadata describing the set of
columns that it's expected to contain
every time we materialize the asset we
record the columns that were included in
the materialization
if the asset is fully reconciled then
these two lists of columns should match
but in the case up here they don't match
the definition includes a column that
the latest materialization does not
so we need to take some action oops um
so we need to take some action in this
case to resolve that
the reconciliation approach can be more
involved because it requires thinking
about all the different ways that an
asset's materializations can stray from
its definition
but it has a few big draws
so instead of trying to keep track in
your head of when assets have drifted
from their materializations you delegate
that bookkeeping to the orchestrator
you can avoid unnecessary computation so
why we compute an asset if nothing about
its inputs have changed
and you get a rationale for why
computation happened for example we
re-materialized asset x because the
columns it had no longer match the
columns that we expected it to have
so at this point here we have this
understanding of the fundamentals of
software defined assets and how we
manage change inside of them
and with that out of the way i'd like to
talk a little bit about how
software-defined assets fit into the
context of what's happened in the world
of data in the last
couple of years
if you ask 20 people for definitions of
the modern data stack you'll get at
least 20 different answers but here's a
fairly bland one that i think at least
isn't going to ruffle too many feathers
and will work for our purposes
the modern data stack is a set of tools
and practices that have dramatically
simplified common patterns for working
with data
at least in part i think that the modern
data stack owes its success to an
embrace of declarative principles for
example in the past to build a derived
table you would write an airflow task
that issues a create table statement to
your database
nowadays you're more likely to define
the table directly as a dbt
model
in the past if you wanted to ingest the
table into your data warehouse from your
production database you would write an
airflow task that executes a sync
oops
nowadays you're more likely to just tell
5tran or airbyte or miltano that you
want that table to exist in your
warehouse
with these declarative approaches you
get all the declarative benefits that we
discussed earlier so it's understandable
why they're attractive and why we're
moving in this direction
but there's something that's lost as
well
and to understand it we need to go back
in time and take a look at the
pre-modern world
in the pre-modern world you'd use an
imperative orchestrator like airflow to
invoke computations across a variety of
frameworks as we covered earlier there
are a lot of problems with this world
having an imperative orchestration layer
fosters a lot of chaos and forces you to
constantly translate between the world
of assets and the world of tasks
but there's also some important bath
water that we shouldn't throw out with
the baby here
this centralized orchestration layer
makes it easy to understand everything
that's running in one place
and to make sure that everything is
running in the right order even across
tools
in the world of the modern data stack
purpose-built tools for each of the
verticals essentially roll their own
orchestrators
so each of the tools shown here
except python which we'll get to in a
minute offers its own way to schedule
work and view the assets that are
defined inside of it
i think this loss of a central control
plan is a regression
the lack of a shared orchestration layer
results in operationally fragile data
platform
when dependencies cross tool boundaries
for example when the tables that you
derive via dbt depend on tables that are
synced from a production database
it becomes difficult to get a coherent
view of what's going on
so when dealing with this situation a
common pattern is to try to time the
schedules so that the syncs will
complete before the derived tables are
rebuilt
but this is pretty brittle if the syncs
take longer than expected there's an
overlap in the timing
and then the derived tables will get
rebuilt using stale data
so it's easy to lose track of what ran
what's supposed to ran and whether
things ran in the right order
and you might also notice that python
has largely been left behind from this
picture by focusing on specialty tools
that simplify common data patterns we
risk losing our ability to run
generalized computation when we need it
so we're forced to choose between a
a unified approach that's stuck in an
imperative paradigm
or b a declarative approach without a
unified control
plane i don't think there's any
fundamental reason we need this
trade-off we can have a declarative
asset-based orchestrator that supports
polyglot compute
dagster allows delegating computation
and asset definitions to external tools
like dbt and airbite while maintaining a
unified control plane over all of them
that control plane is declarative you
don't lose sight of the assets you're
working with when you schedule them in
your orchestrator
and it makes python a native citizen of
the modern data stack
python asset definitions can co-exist
alongside dbt models etc
so here's a dagster asset definition
graph that spans python dbt and airbyte
the three assets at the top are tables
that are populated via airbyte6
materializing them via dagser for
example clicking on that button when
we're on the asset page for one of them
results in a call to airbyte to run the
syncs
the assets in the middle with the orange
tags are dvt models
materializing them in dagster clicking
on the button you know on the asset page
results in a call to dbt either cli rbc
server or dbt cloud
and the asset with a light blue tag on
the lower right is an asset that's
computed using python downstream of one
of these dbt models
so that brings us to the end of our
journey
let's boil it down to the main things
that we talked about
the world of data needs a new spanning
abstraction which is the
software-defined asset
a software-defined asset is a
declaration in code of an asset that
should exist and how to compute it
defining assets in software enables a
new way of managing data that makes it
easier to trust easier to organize and
easier to change
the seat of the asset definition is the
orchestrator
the system that you use to manage change
should have assets as its primary
abstraction and is in the best position
to act as their source of truth
when it comes to the modern data stack
software-defined assets allow python to
become a first-class citizen
an asset-based orchestration offers a
unified control plane without
sacrificing
a declarative approach
so thank you very much i'd love to
answer any questions you have in my
office hours which i believe are
immediately after lunch